thank you for welcoming us into your
home guys thanks for coming time it's a
beautiful space a little different than
the Big Brother house a little bit do
you miss that house at all is there
anything you're like oh I wish I could
go back I do I just missed the whole
kind of experience yeah just hanging out
with everybody was cool
everybody and Bob on the intercom
telling us what to do oh yeah that's my
favorite what was the hardest or
weirdest part of adjusting to life back
in the real world
I don't know dealing with yeah how many
people actually are invested in our
lives and like paid attention and
actually watch the show and it's like
really fathom it when you're in there
yeah it's so weird cuz like just in our
daily lives it's so much harder to get
things done I know they give you the
whole season when you walk out of that
house that you can watch have you
watched your whole season we've watched
everything but the finale I don't know
why we haven't watched the familiar yet
can't wait to tear these two apart I'm
evil how did you feel about how you came
across on the show I was I mean I I knew
I was gonna be kind of like the and I
was fine with that but it's like the
real person comes out at the end and I
think I think that that kind of show
showed at the very end so I'm ok with
that
yeah I'm thankful that she made it long
enough where they have no choice but to
see like the real Angela you know right
back at you and then the finale you were
telling me this one you think's the one
you feel that way yeah absolutely
can you holding hands the whole time
we've been here this is it's it's the
real deal like next level oh yeah yeah
you guys have not been apart no at all
since Big Brother ended no more than a
few hours no that's all I can hey what
have you learned about each other since
you left the house I like it a lot yeah
yeah yeah
so what's the next step for you guys do
you see engagement marriage all those
things are you thank you okay
that's like question for him yeah these
things happen naturally no rushing yet
enjoying a stage of the relationship
this is where I know very okay no hurry
we go play mmm
do you see more reality TV in your
future like what you want to do a series
the two of you about your lives do
another competition I'm pretty much open
to anything like the world throws our
way so if that's what's in our future
then let's go for it anything that
involves both of us okay cannot split
them up yeah impossible mine sorry to go
up from Big Brother they do love to
bring that's back do you want to go back
and play again and try and win or is
once enough I'm open to the opportunity
of doing again but I will not do it
without him I could not be gone for
three months yeah I would die I would be
so perfect
yeah I don't know if I could do it again
anyway who from your season are you
still in regular contact with peanut
peanut Casey of course Louis takes me
time to Rachel quite a level 6 there is
a level 6
I'm level six and what goes down in that
group Jack right now we're trying to
organize something for New Year's trying
ever you can get everyone together okay
but it's always hard to get you know six
of us living different lives all over
the country together that Casey texts
right back it's been three days it's
Casey the hardest to get a home this is
the hardest to get a hold of you know is
everywhere but it's fine
mom another chain yeah yeah she's living
it she's living it who is like the
easiest to get a response back from her
great shawl or Winson okay Rachel and
Winston always always come back with the
quick responses they appreciate that